well hardest things on your path to
becoming a developer and learning that
code is the consistency this is probably
the number one thing people would say
when learning and code is it's about
repetition it's about doing it every day
is about working at it again and again
and again and you know if you don't take
any breaks you're gonna get there much
quicker than if you do take breaks and
so consistency is something that a lot
of people struggle with in all aspects
of their life so I'm gonna talk to you
about five ways that when I was learning
to be a self-taught dev I made sure that
I was able to code every day I was
consistent with my my learning and that
I was able to finally just get it right
and just finally grab and understand oh
my god it's starting to click these are
the things that I made sure so that I
had a consistent path so the first thing
is about getting rid of distractions
eliminating things oftentimes you are
trying to make a career change you're
trying to make a life change and
learning code and all those things so
it's a it's a big change and you need to
sort of refactor some of your life to
make to make it a change that will
actually last and so you need to start
getting rid of distractions I was really
the first thing that I did and those
were a couple different categories of
distractions and you know some of you
may disagree so you know Dylan I don't
want to get rid of all of it it sounds
like you're getting rid of all the fun
right well you have to understand when
you're when you're taking on a you know
a career change or a life change your
your life and career are changing and
you need to reflect that so for me I
personally sold all my game systems like
I was I had a issue where I couldn't I
said they couldn't I didn't have the
self-control to have a game console in
the house and not play it when I should
be coding when I should be going to meet
up when I should be reading a book about
software so that's the first things and
that's more than just you know physical
items in the house if you watch your
tongue the TV sell your TV sell your
game systems
surround yourself with like-minded
individuals as well right so one thing
that I had to do was I had to stop
hanging out with my friends who were you
know losers essentially and losers in
the sense that they you know they just
want to go out drink every night and you
know they were okay going and working
there
you know minimum wage job in the morning
that's if that's what you want to do but
to me that's not those aren't the people
are gonna help me become a better
developer so surround yourself with
people who are trying to who are
developers are trying to be better
developers and slowly those distractions
whether they be friends whether they be
game consoles in my case will slowly
weave them out because you're going to
be changing as a person but you can in
the in the short term you can get rid of
the stuff that you don't need that are
just items relatively quickly
number two is some pretty much setting a
schedule setting a schedule the the
thing here is it is very easy to say
that you are going to you know work hard
every day but what does that mean what
does that really mean and when you have
a schedule you are forcing yourself into
a situation where no matter what from
the hours of 7 a.m. to 8 a.m. I'm going
to be doing an hour of something from
the hours of you know 7 p.m. to 9 p.m.
every night I give those examples
because those are the hours that I work
on my YouTube channel on my courses on
becoming a better developer in the same
hours that I worked when I was learning
to code before I was a developer because
you know most of us probably aren't
self-employed probably aren't
independently wealthy so we have to find
the time and when you find the time you
know so far we've eliminated the
distractions which in theory should
create the time so that we can stick to
our schedule and it's hard to do but it
is one of the ways to stick with being
consistent to consistently work hard and
you'll continue to make progress if you
do that now with tip number three is
having clearly defined milestones now
what does that really mean in reality
what we're really talking about is
having goals and knowing when you have a
those goals it's very easy to have one
goal right I want to be a developer
Dylan that's my one and only goal okay
well what are the goals you need to
achieve to accomplish that goal
right goal number one set up a github
right all right cool I said it would
help I have a new project cool a little
baby milestone your first project on
github awesome
you haven't LinkedIn cool you've worked
on your Linkedin you've got it out there
oh you built your personal portfolio so
I can react within angular whatever it
is if you're a front-end of back into
but you built some project all these
little goals and milestones understand
what it is that you want to accomplish
if your end goal is to become a do
front-end developer you need to have ten
mini goals on your path to getting there
that include all the languages you need
to be familiar with the framework that
you want to learn the projects that
you're building in that framework etc
etc etc not only will he give you a
better idea in a learning path that you
need to have a lot of times it gets very
overwhelming especially in the the web
dev world because there's new stuff
coming out all shout love you should you
know Python Django what should I learn
you can do your own research on that but
what you need to do is after you've done
your research after you've talked with
your mentor after you've you know watch
videos read blogs you need to define
that path on how to get to your end goal
and those mini milestones you get there
not only will it keep you motivated
because you'll see like oh I'm getting
closer because you're either going zero
to 100 if your only goal here is to be a
dev you're gonna feel like you're at
zero until you're a hunter and that's
very demotivating so unis have those
clearly clearly defined goals it'll also
give you the confidence for when you are
ready to start throwing out those job
applications when you are ready to start
saying you know what I'm ready let's go
interview right let's go start
submitting those resumes let's start
doing those technically interviews those
those phone screens so those clearly
defined goals are gonna be what allow
you to stay motivated and it's all nice
all right I'm you know I'm one step
closer so that was something that I
would think is a big deal that you need
to have setup in in your learning path
to stay consistent
alright this may come as a little bit of
a
like well didn't you just say you need
to get rid of those distracting France
well yes but you need to expose your
process to other people so that they're
on the same page and that doesn't mean
that I'm telling you to kick out your
mother kick out your brother from your
life or anything like that or your kids
because you know they take up your time
and energy to a degree but for those
people who you're like you know they're
not a negative influence on me but they
do they are time right if you have kids
you need to watch them you know your
husband or your wife you know why you're
out learning that's taking energy away
from the family and so everyone needs to
be on the same page right one thing that
I did when I was living with my mother
and I was coding is I had a sign and I
basically did the Pomodoro Technique
except I did about an hour so if you're
not familiar Pomodoro Technique you work
then you take a break for certain
amounts so typically people do about
thirty minutes and then they take a
10-minute break so what I did was I
worked for about an hour and my mother
loved her death she'd always be knock on
the door hey you want anything to eat
you know hey can you help me move the
couch all this surf stuff not that she's
trying to bother me but this is you know
when you are coding you need to get into
a groove right you need to you need to
be able to sit down and it might take
you 15-20 minutes to ramp up and then
you get 40 minutes productivity an hour
everyone's different but if you let the
people in your life know that okay well
you know you let your children know if
daddy has the sign on the door says you
know busy learning or whatever it is
don't come in you know go ask mommy and
then you have 40 minutes and you just
have people respect that and then in my
case I would put on the door and I come
out say hey it's mom is there anything
you need you know April anything I can
help you with whatever it may be and
reach out to them but it is important
that people understand because they may
not right my mother to this day still
thinks I'm just in there playing video
games right she thinks I'm just in there
playing Starcraft uh-huh you know that's
what she's so but she did respect the
fact that I you know set some boundaries
to a degree and and said hey you know
what I'm I'm I'm just trying to learn
here I'm trying to better myself and to
do that I need I need to be able to
focus I need the time that it is
required to
compsat and when you said when you've
set those those boundaries other people
are on the same page and then you've you
also feel sense of pride because now
people know what you're trying to
accomplish and now it's like oh well I
don't want to let mom's down I don't
want to let the girlfriend down whatever
maybe the husband down so I encourage
you to explain your process and get
people to be on the same page as you
last but not least is a little bit more
of a flexible be flexible with yourself
a lot of what we stop talking about
scheduling having organized goals being
able to inform people of you know how
can they work within your system so that
everyone's on the same page you get the
time you need but being flexible with
yourself is probably the number one
thing that you need to understand to a
degree right what do I mean by being
flexible with yourself well if you're
trying to learn to code or even you're a
developer you're just trying to get
better and you're saying look man I'm
already a developer I want to go from
junior to senior and I want to do it in
a year I want to build a run a write a
book I want to build a course whatever
it is there's gonna be days where you
don't want to do it there's gonna be
days where you're tired you know you
just got off work your boss just
verbally abuse your eye whatever it is
you know your boyfriend dumped you your
girlfriend is cheating on you whatever
it may be right there's gonna be days
where you're just in a awful place could
nothing could happen you just tired
you don't bored you're stuck on
something and for those days it's okay
to take a break no but it is okay to
change your attitude and change how
you're going to refocus yourself so if
you've been hacking away on a project
and you've just hit something and you're
at a wall how can you continue your
learning path how can you continue to be
consistent within yourself well you can
you can read some blogs for instance
learn about stuff you can watch you know
- our talk on es6 es7 whatever it is
whatever you're interested in you can go
to hackathons you can go to meetups you
have all this sort of stuff where you
know go hang out with a friend who
hopefully is a developer and you know do
some pair programming
do some just change it up is what I'm
trying to say for those days that you're
like god man I just I'm tired like I
love this I love this but I'm so tired
today
and I don't want to do it well do
something else that's still gonna help
you accomplish those milestones it's
gonna make you a better developer and
make you stay on the path right because
the thing is is every time every day
even if it feels like the tiniest of
steps you're that consistency is moving
you one step closer to your goal a one
step closer to the milestone you know
each one of these milestones are like a
gas station we're just filling up again
before you get to your final destination
and that consistency through all of it
is really what you're gonna need to
succeed in any aspect of your software
career and I highly encourage you to try
and keep it fun keep it fresh and keep
it consistent because consistency will
be what takes you to the next level of
your career wherever they may be but you
know guys that's my five tips on how to
be consistent how to work hard
essentially and stay on the path
whatever your path may be so I hope you
found it helpful thank you for watching
the video and check out my channel
sometime I guess